Joe Theismann form NFL quarterback for
the Redskins a Super Bowl champion and
NFL MVP joining us on the show good
morning joe where do we stand with this
franchise right now I think based upon
what you reported Dan and talked about
them you know I don't really know I have
no more information than you have
regarding what might be coming out
we know that at this point obviously
there's going to be a name change after
87 years there will no longer be the
Washington Redskins and there will be
some other Washington name attached and
logo attached to the franchise
interestingly enough in 1972 the the
logo itself was designed by a Native
American modeled after basically the
buffalo nickel and see before I ever
really got into this conversation about
the name and this has been going on for
decades this isn't all of a sudden come
overnight you know that I wanted to talk
to Native Americans and get their
opinion on what they thought about the
name the Washington Redskins and I'd say
85% of those that I talked to we're very
positive about it they were proud of it
they were proud of the heritage they
were glad that the team represented the
Native Americans of this country and
then there's a percentage that doesn't
like it and that exists today but for
whatever reason and economically I'm
sure as part of it the there's going to
be a change and and we move forward with
it but you know the other thing - it's
interesting Dan is what I thought about
is what's going on in society today is
July 3rd July 3rd the Redskins made an
announcement and said you know we're
gonna address this issue we're gonna
look at it and all of a sudden eight
days later a change is coming I guess I
asked myself this question we've talked
about activism in this country we've
talked about things that should change
but yet they don't if the Washington
football organization can do something
in eight days why can't other branches
of life get something done in a hurry
what are we waiting for
I guess that's my question yeah but the
Redskins waited a long time on this Joe
I feel like you know I think if we
hadn't been where we are socially and
yeah change you know I mean it's it but
it's it's a change that basically has
come and those of us that played under
the monarch
The Washington Redskins Stan I mean we
we want championships there there's a
there's a great legacy in history that
we're a part of and very proud of and
I'm excited for this young group of kids
and it's a very young football team I'm
excited for them to sort of establish
their own numbers going forward and is
this one question I've yet to find an
answer to maybe your guys and you can
help will the records of the Washington
Redskins as of what they were carry
forward to the new Washington franchise
I mean did the Houston oiler records
carry on to the Tennessee Titans or was
it just a whole new beginning when it
came to those players that are going to
be a part of the franchise well it's
just a name change it's not a location
change because Houston changed and went
to Tennessee the Baltimore Colts went to
Indianapolis the Clemens Brown yeah even
yeah so I I think that there's a little
bit of separation there but I'm gonna
guess if the Colts numbers are the same
or under the same umbrella in Baltimore
as they are in Indianapolis how well do
you know Daniel Snyder and can you could
you offer suggestions on how to make
this franchise better well first of all
dan has been a fan I've known Dan for a
number of years and we're friends and
and good friends the thing is is in you
know he's he's a he's a fan he was
always a fan first I mean when he was a
little kid this was a dream of his to
own the Washington Redskins that dream
came to fruition roughly 20 years ago
and it's been a struggle ever since
trying to find the right combination and
there's other franchise that franchises
that have gone through this same
situation where you have a degree of
success and in all of a sudden you try
and look for that magic formula again
and for one reason or another I can say
the last three years this team has been
hit with the injury bug more than any
team in the National Football League
we've had more guys when I are in the
last three years the most teams have
intent so the lack of players and it's a
its consistency and it's a players game
and if you don't have the players
particularly the quarterback position I
got hurt 35 years ago and I believe
they've had 37 different starting
quarterbacks in that period of time
where you take a look at teams like the
49ers teams like the Packers that have
had consistency over over a couple of
decades with different people and that's
I think what we're searching for and
Dwayne Haskins is a very fine young
quarterback that we hope will be a kid
going forward that can you know beat
sort of the beginning of stability at
that position on this football team but
it starts with that position yeah and
I'm trying to think when's the last time
you had a quarterback where you went I
feel pretty confident with the franchise
in his hands it's been a long time it
really has I mean I just to put in
perspective not to to to to horn so to
speak but I'm second to in Sammy Baugh
two consecutive starts for the
organization in the history of the
organization at 99 and Sammy I believe
was a hundred and thirteen or something
like that
but when you have someone who played 35
years ago and is second in the
franchise's history when it comes to
consecutive starts you know that there's
been instability at that position I
believe Marc rippen is third at like 78
so they you have to have somebody line
up and play year after year after year
after year and you need consistent
coaching which is another thing we've
had a lot of different coaches come
through I think Ron Rivera is is the
perfect choice for this football
franchise his staff has veterans it has
young people but there's been just a
lack of consistency in different
positions and it's been tough and it's
not the dance not try and listen you
know everybody sort of jumps all over
Dan well does he trying too hard Joe
sometimes the owners get too involved in
and we know they made their money in a
different you know industry they in and
you know the Blue Bloods turn it over to
their people and say you coach you be
the GM I'm gonna stay out of the way
he's dan Snyder too involved no not he
there was a time when he was involved
more heavily than he is now but what
he's done is he stepped back and he's
trying to find the right combination
like I said I believe that this is the
right combination going forward
finally for him I think there's a so
much change that's happening so much
almost confusion when it comes to what
needs to be done but I think he's got a
clear vision and picture of what he
wants now he is he's involved as any
owner
you when you have franchises that are
worth billions of dollars you have every
right to be involved you're writing
checks you're writing big checks so you
want to know what's going on but when it
comes to the day-to-day operations other
people will have input into it and just
if you listen to the conversations and
read some of the stuff regarding Ron
Rivera and Dan Schneider in conversation
about the name Ron's very heavily
involved you know this isn't just gonna
be Dan's gonna say I want this and it's
gonna happen no he's very they're very
heavily involved we're talking to Joe
Theismann former NFL MVP he's got a new
book and just published last month how
to be a champion everyday and timeless
keys to success you saw dak Prescott and
dak Prescott is probably going to you
know sign that franchise tag here would
you invest in dak Prescott long-term if
you were the Dallas Cowboys if I was the
Dallas Cowboys I would do exactly what
Jerry Jones is doing I would offer him
the contract of four years I believe the
numbers somewhere between 32 and 35
million per year with 100 million
guaranteed I would make that offer
because there there's changes the league
we don't know what this football season
is gonna look like we don't know if
there's going to be any type of OTAs or
many much of a mini camp to be honest
with you and then we don't know what the
seasons gonna be like plus he's under a
new coach he has a new system to learn
and and the other thing is is the
Cowboys won a five-year deal from what I
understand dak wants a four you know the
number somewhere in the low 30 millions
I think that's a fair number dak rolls
the dice at 31 four and says hey look I
may take a chance and be franchise they
can franchise them again I think next
year at 38 but they don't really know
what they have at this point and part of
it is the economic stand in the game you
know salary cap is based upon revenue if
the Redskins not the Reds if the
Redskins if the Washington franchise or
all the franchises don't make the money
they think and it's estimated to be
somewhere in the neighborhood of a
hundred million dollars less per
franchise you're talking three points
some odd billion dollars and now what's
the cap going to be next year we've seen
the cap continue to go up and up and up
but in this environment there isn't
ain't guarantee of anything but do you
think sighs I think franchise I think as
it stands I mean I think dak really had
a chance to do something special because
and I've always believed this the
quarterback is the single most dependant
player on the field I mean you just have
to depend on so many different things
guys catching the ball defenses stopping
people kicks being made blocks being
made you're you're part of it really is
just a part and he's got some really
good tremendous pieces on the offensive
side with him and like I said for him if
he should sign a five-year contract
because he's never gonna see the fifth
year anyway you know if he does what he
expects to do and what the Cowboys want
him to do he may not even see the he may
not even see year four before he gets
another deal on top of it so I don't
know what I'm not I don't know what the
hang-up is I know that the offer sounds
you know like Jerry is being fair and
and and equitable with them and you know
I wish them all the luck in the world
going out there and if you're gonna roll
the dice you know go make them pay we're
starting to see I guess it's a trend now
and maybe you it was there but it was in
the embryonic stages and that is the
quarterback who can run put pressure on
you but also be able to throw the deep
ball and Lamar Jackson it feels like his
blueprint is I can put pressure on you
on the edges and I if you bite on me
running I can throw the deep ball and
try to get some home runs here is the
future of the NFL the style of Patrick
mahomes or of Lamar Jackson or someone
else
III think somewhat of a combination you
know Patrick isn't in that class when it
comes to running like Lamar does or even
Cuyler Murray out in Arizona there's
another one who has uses his legs a lot
Cam Newton found out that if you use
your legs a lot and you can't throw the
ball out of the pocket it'll wear you
down in a hurry and beat you up I think
that you still have to be able to
operate out of the pocket especially
with the gun the way it is now and the
the spread offenses that we're running
you still have to be able to do that on
a consistent basis because at this level
you can't run around and take the
pounding over a year after year after
year and expect to be able to play a
long time I think Lamar is a very unique
individual course an MVP of the lake
Patrick mahomes is another one who has
the ability to escape Jimmy Garoppolo is
another one who has that ability to be
able to move around but I still believe
foundationally you have to be able to
operate out of the pocket look at the
guys that have won the championships
Peyton Manning even Aaron Rodgers stand
you know Aaron has the ability to move
but we don't see him do it a lot of
course Tom Brady has six championships
so when you start to put together the
and look at the way the offenses are
constructed you have to be able to start
and operate out of the pocket and then
oh by the way if you need to put
pressure on people I will say this about
Lamar Lamar I thought improved
tremendously last year throwing the
football down the field and the thing
that his skills and Kyler Murray's in
particular present is that a defense
can't just put their ears back and come
after because you can't give them escape
lanes you want to be able to keep him in
the pocket especially Kyler at his size
you want to make him throw from the
forest you want to make him throw
through the trees because he's not gonna
be able to see a lot of things down the
field I know as a 6-foot guy myself that
when I played it's you know it's
difficult you're really not you're
throwing in between lanes you're not
throwing over people but also you didn't
get the credit and maybe there weren't
enough people after you you know drew
Brees gets a lot of credit because Drew
Brees had his size hey got you don't
have to be six four you were six-foot
you were the league MVP but it felt like
you were an anomaly and people weren't
gonna go oh it like Russell Wilson you
know Russell Wilson I think got an
opportunity because of Drew Brees but
you know you were prior your predecessor
to Drew Brees as far as being successful
and not being six for like Dan Marino or
John Elway well there were you know
there were other guys before me like Bob
Griese was one I think Roger Staubach
wasn't the tallest of all maybe a couple
inches taller than I but the game has
evolved in so many different ways from
rules from the wide-open nature of it
from the different positions we used to
you yo you went we went through this
with wide receivers we want that we want
the tall guy so we can throw the ball in
a general area and let him make a play
then we wanted the quick one to be able
to get down the field then we wanted the
fast one and it football does that it
has its abs and flows we want the big
corner because we want to play cover two
now we want the little corner because
gonna go man-to-man and and at the
quarterback position now I think we're
leaning more and more towards the fact
that we want somebody with mobility but
again Drew Brees throws out of the
pocket all the time
Drew's not gonna run away from anybody
Eli never ran away from anybody in New
York so but there aren't a lot of them
coming out of college day and that's the
thing is the college game is a little
bit different than ours because for
example you take guys to throw bubble
screens all the time take it take a
university or throws bubble screens Ohio
State okay you can have 35 40 50
touchdown passes and have and and 15 of
them are gonna be because somebody made
somebody miss and ran a lot of yards so
it's the concepts of the offenses that
the kids are coming out of it's the size
of the kids it's their athleticism these
are all things you have to take into
consideration plus again I don't know
what football is gonna look like
in 2021 more or less 20 but I do know
that the rookies are behind gonna be
behind the eight ball here you've got
the young free agents you've got new
coaches that are trying and still
systems all these things are done by as
you and I talk now and zoom Joe has a
bookshelf behind him and he's only got
four books in the bookshelf and they're
all the same book that Joe just put out
it it's Joe's boy I mean this one well
there's you got five books there Joe
Joe's got his book there and how to be a
champion six timeless keys to success
great tan great hair you got it all Joe
you look like a success as most
important thing is you look you're
looking good it's great to talk to you
as always Joe thank you thanks great to
catch up with you take care of yourself
guys they say met Joe Theismann